y'a pas de problème dis moi toi tu t'es
con fait corps pour la dernière fois
on vient une paille avant mais tu t'es
confessé déjà revu au lit parce qu'ils
en ont la part de communes ici non ah
ouais ça me faisait du bien
chipadze est là parce qu'on sortait être
allégée comme après après
résultats d'analysés on pensait qu'on
est séronégatif agréable si bien
sensation oui c'est exactement la même
sensation merci
dis moi j'ai en fait été dur à vivre
pendant tout ce temps d'être le beauf de
service me portent sérieusement j'ai
joué les personnages qui était un petit
peu caricaturaux il est une tête de
français c'est vrai j'avais peut-être
deux français et je mets cette moustache
l'ain
je m'étais fait poussé par le service
militaire en compostage c'est pourquoi
ces inaperçu puis maintenant je passais
plus du tout une averse s'est fait
souffrir de devoir en france juniors à
l'heure tous les soirs dans les arènes
de l'info canal + oui enfin une image
c'est une caricature d'une image qui
était une caricature comme moi je ne
faisais c'est le look le pénis qizhen
avant d'écouter liste non du pénis est
plus grave que ça s'est passé comment le
jour où tu a rasé sa moustache en
dessous tu aurais préféré avoir le
succès l'argent que tu vas aujourd'hui
ou être le sosie de thierry lhermitte
par exemple ce que je connais tous ses
défauts au teil
si tu devais être incarné tu préfères
être incarnée en maudit allen dont alain
delon
or vous dirai rien sur pattes raison
d'une provision les rôles de jeunes
premiers sont assez chiant à jouer
c'est vrai que tu vas aller en enfer ou
paradis
je ne suis pas bien mais ce qui me
terrifie c'est que quand je vois les
gens qui sont perçus d'aller au paradis
fout un peu les landes
tous ces gens bien pensants bien honnête
propre saada il en fait les gens que
j'apprécie
il se retrouverait plus tôt en enfer
si tu devais mourir ton petit arthur
savez une seule chose à lui dire ça
serait quoi
pas trop de tristesse demain je crois
que kaka saveurs qui les avaient pas
pris part à jouer un rôle énorme je
prends la tête